good morning ladies and gentlemen
a warm welcome to the design track in
tech innovation 2020
i'm mark the executive director of
design singapore council
and thank you ipi for inviting us back
again to the tech innovation conference
this year's theme is about catalyzing
innovation with design
but can design actually be a catalyst
for innovation
and what exactly does design mean
well a study by the design management
institute in 2016
shown that design-led companies deliver
on average more than
200 percent returns over the s p
500 than non-design-led companies
so what exactly are these design-led
companies doing differently
and again what does design mean well
if steve jobs put it aptly design is
more than just making things look pretty
it's actually about making things work
and in fact it is a key
to problem solving and innovation
innovating
this process is now known as design
thinking
design-led companies use design to
create value and unlock
innovation and opportunities and for
successful innovation and transformation
that take place you need
these three elements to be in place
first
technological feasibility second
justifiability and third market
desirability
a good design-led process enables an
organization to bring these three
elements together
in order for innovation to take place
and this process also needs to be
underpinned by great empathy for
your user needs and the experience with
your product
service or experience
well actually now here's a great example
of how a company
leveraged designed to propel innovation
in nike
nike has actually completely reinvented
its true manufacturing process
and rather than setting out to design a
new show the company designed a new way
to conceptualize
the manufacturing of an athletic shoe
itself
nike's designers pioneered the new nike
flyknit technology to deliver a peak
performance shoe
for athletes in a sustainable way it
actually took them 195
tries using the reinvented manufacturing
process before
the flyknit racer was actually born and
i also this
was more environmentally friendly and
reduced wastage by
some 80 as compared to other traditional
nike footwear
such as the power of using design and
design thinking
where you start with how you can make
your products or services better for
your customers
and then balancing that out with
technological and business viability
this is also what we at design singapore
strive to do
and that is helping businesses adopt
design and design thinking
as a key enabler for them to drive
profitable and desirable human-centered
innovation
design singapore is actually the
national agency for design in singapore
our vision is to help singapore become
an innovation driven economy and the
lovable city
design by design by 2025
and we are constantly working closely
with the industry design consultants
and both public and private sector to
help drive
business transformation through the use
of design
recognizing the importance of designing
technological innovation our partner ipi
invited us to helm an inaugural design
track at last year's
tech innovation conference and this
session was very well received by the
tech community
and we invited prominent design
professionals and practitioners
to share
and this year we are bringing you two
plenaries one on sustainability and the
other on smart and livable cities
each plenary is connected by three
prominent speakers
pioneers in their own fields in the
space of design and innovation
and we're honored to have them grace
today's session
we've also added two new segments in
this year's design track
the design runway and the design think
tank
and much like ipi's crowd pitching and
crowd sourcing
but for designers and for solutions
primed at using design
so we hope you'll have a fruitful
session of great takeaways on the value
of design and its role in catalyzing
innovation
and once again i'd like to thank all the
speakers who have graciously offered the
time and effort in making this design
track
come to life and i'm sure it'll be an
inspiring
and illuminating one and with that thank
you
good afternoon everybody it is truly
a pleasure to be back in singapore it is
my
deepest wish that i was there with you
and not
sitting here where i am at the moment at
my mother's house in
ohio today's theme
2021 our new world order
what's going to come we all know this
little virus
very often i'm alison asked if i'm
sitting in a little
bench looking up into the sky as i think
about the future and the answer is
no i wish i could but not all the time
usually i'm also like all of us trying
to
calm thoughts and pull together what's
happening and make sense
what's happening tomorrow and today but
one thing we do know
is that our economies our lives in so
many places around the world
went from full speed to zero there was a
great emptiness just like here at dth in
zurich
right now work or in the trams all over
the world
or in the skies no longer flying
or this is sometimes a good thing
actually
very short short control lines i mean
bad for business but
good for the traveler but there's also
great togetherness which we've been
feeling
and to me it's really fascinating to
look at these different
types of togethernesses these way in
which we have
like we are right now come together in
in this zoom this digital world
where many thought it would be
impossible to transform our businesses
and all of a sudden now
we're interacting in this way as a
matter of
the new normal and the question for all
of us
is really what will normal look like
in our really crazy vuca world
what curves are we going to see and when
are we going to see them which ones will
return
which ones are going to keep the way
they are forever which one will be bent
which ones will continue to fall but
really what will normal look like
this is on all of our minds every single
one of us
from the prime minister down to the
youngest
newest newborn baby okay maybe the
newborn babies aren't thinking about
what normal will be like
they're just trying to figure out what
the world is going to be like
but in any case we're all trying to
think about that and as our good friend
peter hoe always says
it is complicated and it's complex
what's interesting for me is to think
about these two
issues and the question of
how it has impacted us really has
depended upon whether you set
sit or stand to work
huge difference how this has impacted us
huge impact if you're sitting
but we can go home but if you're
standing
what happens there interesting to think
of the difference
covet 19 has been an accelerator of the
inevitable
failing business models have only failed
faster
the digital transformation which is no
longer the sunday or being discussed in
the
in all of the halls and conference rooms
is this
someday is now a must and how could we
not
have transformed it has also
increased the appreciation of moments
which really
matter sort of a rediscovery of this
interaction and i truly believe this has
been
for me a fascinating insight the
efficiency of the transactional
how many people still want to go across
the city
to a meeting which takes 15 minutes
which you could have easily done on zoom
the desire for the interpersonal like i
would love
to be able to be there with you to be
able to afterwards go
and have a dinner together the
importance of this
and the necessity of the meandering and
the creative i have yet to find
a digital media which is actually
as good as sitting together around a
table with a whiteboard
so we've actually figured out the
differences between these we've also
have an incredibly increased awareness
of global supply chains
there was a dearth of items which were
unexpected
and a rediscovery of the possibility of
local
in different parts of the world the
question of how can we become
more local it's also been a crash course
in the fragility of globalization
it was shockingly easy to close up
borders
here in europe i was shocked at how
quickly
the borders between the european nations
just went up
the armies were mobilized and boom
and actually it's been a crash course in
this understanding
of the new global order
the question of for all of us of course
is where will these new alliances lead
what will this new global order look
like
so what will normal look like
well we've been seeing it and for us
now the question is of stickiness
what will stick because we are going to
have a vaccine this virus will become
part of every one of our dnas of yours
and of mine
so what will stick well
one thing we do know that when flying
into washington just a few weeks ago
on november 6th or 7th there was a big
question of
stickiness with the outgoing president
and how sticky he would be
but we do know i'm just going to leave
that to the side we do
know that the new normal is going to
look a lot like it did a year ago
right marina bay is going to still be
a magnet it's going to be still be
stunning the gardens by the bay
are going to be blooming it's going to
be gorgeous it's going to be hotter than
heck in summer
right it's so the normal is still going
to look a lot like it did a year ago
chicago is still going to be an endless
city of
lights san francisco is still going to
have the golden gate bridge
central park all of these urban areas
are still going to remain vibrant as
they have
for hundreds or thousands of years
it's not going to go away right
this is for me quite interesting and
quite important
we'll still be wondering where our food
is going to come from
whether it's the fish farms or whether
it's
food farms but what is going to be
different
is going to be a digital twist and this
is what we have seen
and we know that digital twist is
real and the question for all of us is
of course what do we do
with this new digital twist because
change is constant none of us can stop
it
and here we see the urban heat island
effect across the nation
from this and this is so fascinating for
me
to see what can we do to cool singapore
this comes from the singapore eth center
in in singapore this research on
the future designing the future
everything inconvenient will change so
all we have to do
is think about points of inconvenience
in our daily lives and this is where
design
has its forte to understand how to
change those things
right to look at those points of
inconvenience and to deeply understand
them
as we change as humans
think about our port we're already
thinking about the next and the next
port at one time
it was beautifully important and
convenient
to have those ships come into the city
and now we don't want them anywhere
close to us we want them way out there
so the definition of convenience changes
with time as well
but the interesting thing now complexity
is now free
now that i find it fascinating
when we print steel when we print
concrete we do 3d printing it doesn't
matter to the machine
whether it's a straight line or a curved
line
so the question then becomes for us what
are we going to do
with this new fact that complexity
is free what are we going to do this
is a design challenge that is phenomenal
not only this physical complexity but
also the digital complexity
and you can argue whether or not you
like the forms
because perfectly valid but now we can
free ourselves into new ways of thinking
that we could not even begin to do 10
years ago
incredibly wonderful time especially
when we're
looking at the challenges of climate
change a sea level
rise of biodiversity loss of the great
extinction which we're feeling so
what can we be doing to change that
we're also in an era of augmentation and
this is for me totally
fascination party and this is totally
fascinating
in the building world where we can now
with
digital tools recreate
many craft that we lost
that we totally lost or we can use
augmented reality to understand
how to bend the metal into forms which
our designers can create and then the
craftsmen and women
can bend into place using their goggles
or put blocks together just for fun
or we know the construction is a very
dangerous profession
right it destroys a man or a woman's
body
so now with exoskeletons with augmenting
our physical capability
we can change that
or we can augment our capabilities in
construction and in design
so we can get the best of the human and
the machine so we're actually focusing
on
what people do best and what machines do
best to create
a whole new hybrid design vocabulary
here
some stone hewn by hand but with
holes drilled with millimeter sub
millimeter precision
by drills through the stone this is the
sagrada familia
cathedral in barcelona
another thing that we do know
looking at the future anything that can
be automated
will be automated now for many this is
terrifying because they know
that their job is easily automated
for others it's liberating because
they'll think about
ah if that part's automated we can do
this
so all of us from the design community
need to be thinking about
everything that can be automated will be
so what does that mean
next what can we be doing with this new
capability
now a few other things that go along
with this one is a democratization of
tools
it used to be the domain of specialists
to have specialist knowledge and tools
but now with the internet and with the
digital transformation
we have this deep democratization of
tool sets
so the question is what do we do as a
designer as an engineer
as an architect as just any person on
the street
we also have a popularization of those
techniques through youtube
you can now teach yourself anything i
mean truly
anything so you no longer have to purely
be a specialist
you can learn it yourself and the final
thing with this this is now
a ubiquity of data and this is quite
fascinating it's not always
good data but there's a lot of data
that can be mined and understood so we
understand patterns of human behavior
patterns of city behavior patterns of
natural behavior
that we could never understand before
the last two there has to be and i
believe there will be
a systemic acceptance of the digital
transformation
most bureaucracies don't like change and
singapore has been quite fascinating
because
there's been an encouragement of change
through
the digital nation digital singapore
initiatives
and so how can we continue to increase
the
systemic acceptance of these changes and
integrate them into our practices our
practices
as individuals as professionals
so that for me is quite interesting
because
we all stand at a moment in time
of profound change personal change
environmental change political change
and the question for all of us we have
to ask is
what decisions are we going to be making
to push us in one direction or another
and that for me is a very important
thing like
the sustainable development goals all 17
of these goals
have been agreed by every nation in the
world and
every one of those plus the 169
indicators which stand behind them
are things which i believe everyone
should look at
now i don't expect everyone to remember
all of them but look at them and
understand them because
all of these are critical we talk about
shaping a better world
this is the better world which we need
to be shaping towards
because if we look at the consumption of
stuff this graph shows the time
and the growth of gdp and tracks
typically as the world gets richer as
people
lift themselves out of the poverty we
consume more
stuff we can't keep doing that we can't
keep
doing this my great-grandfather said
we are too poor to buy cheap stuff why
would you ever buy
anything which you know you're going to
throw away
three months from now or build you can
tear it down three years from now
this leads to the circular economy all
of us have an incredibly important role
to play in that
and to understand how we can get this by
design
to be restorative and singapore is
playing a very focused role in this
i encourage you to make sure you're
looking at this to take a look at this
book
collapsed by jared diamond and just take
a look at a couple of the graphs
what happens for civilizations to fail
environmental damage climate change
hostile neighbors
weak trade partners and a failure to
solve societal problems
we stand at that precipice and so we
then also have the role in trying to
co-create
and co-author the future which will then
have a positive
impact and not go down a negative spiral
a piece of homework for you as a
recovering academic is from kate
ralworth donut economics
it has the social foundation in the
middle the sdgs the outer side
is the planetary boundaries please take
a look at this
this is where we have to get to it's
your only piece of homework for me
darwin said it's not the strongest of
species that survives or the most
intelligent
it's the one that's most adaptable to
change we
are an intelligent species so we then
have to be the ones who adopt to the
changes around us
and we understand that we know what's
happening in this
changing world knowledge is a commodity
what you do with it is what matters and
this
is critical for me
think about what we do with the
knowledge which you have
you have the gift of knowledge the gift
of understanding what's happening
to our world around us be curious
make the difference so that you can look
at the next generations
straight in the eye and say i did
everything i could
to make your life better reserve
for future development let's make sure
that future development
is positive thank you ever
ever ever so much singapore for inviting
me to come
back to you and i can't wait to see you
again
thank you my name is mike koch i'm the
managing director
for urban x the accelerator for startups
reimagining city life
built by mini and urban us and i'm going
to talk to you a little bit about our
perspectives on the changing city
landscape
uh i wish that i could be there in
person with you in singapore
one of my favorite cities and really the
model for
uh smart cities globally um
this is a really interesting time and i
think um
cities are re-evaluating transportation
infrastructure
building infrastructure public health
and
and wellness and i think in many ways uh
covet 19 has revealed some of
the inherent um challenges that
that global cities face in the 21st
century
and so um in a time where we've uh sunk
a lot of
um capital into infrastructure how do we
think about
that infrastructure and uh and the
changes
that are to come at a time where cities
are really
under significant pressure and i think
that our
hypothesis is you have to think about
cities holistically you have to think
about
challenges around transportation and
mobility
and traffic the lost productivity due to
traffic you have to think about the
built environment and
and real estate um the future of work
and the way that
uh remote work will will change cities
uh what it means for cities tax roles
what it means for the vibrancy of dense
urban
urban environments and you have to think
about infrastructure and industry
if in fact you're going to think
holistically about climate change and
the carbon challenge and fundamentally
we are really interested in
decarbonization and resilience
strategies and we think that the public
sector
um just can't get there on their own um
and that
what's really needed is new thinking new
approaches to innovation
from um from innovators and from
entrepreneurs and so i would argue that
you know in a very short amount of time
um
cities are have gone through profound
change
and while we may emerge in the second
half of 2021 with some degree of
normalcy i do think that
um there are changes that we will be
grappling with for years to come
and arguably the the most critical
change
um has to do with emissions and and
climate adaptation and mitigation
consider that
um uh because of covid here in the u.s
emissions drop roughly five percent um
what we really need is sustained
emissions drops of
roughly seven and a half percent
annually uh
to get us to net zero uh by 2050
um and and just to keep um our emissions
from
exceeding the scientific consensus of
what's needed
to sustain civilization
we have a whole lot of work to do and so
i think the question is where are the
solutions going to come from
what is a better future looks look like
that doesn't have the same degree of
carbon intensity but
um still has uh vibrancy and
um and and economic growth and i think
that those two things are not mutually
exclusive so
we drawn is a history and a legacy of
um of using crisis as an opportunity
uh to really drive the next stage of
growth and that comes from a gentleman
named sir alexis agonis who was a
an engineer and designer in the late
1950s who created the first mini
uh really as a response to the suez gas
crisis and um and i think that it is
that um heritage and spirit along with
the
know-how uh in terms of execution of
design and engineering or global
distribution networks and also
um the reach of a brand like bmw that is
a real value
proposition to startups and so
again we think that you know there's a
really related opportunity to rethink
city life to use design
um for new approaches and and new
solutions whether those are hardware
or software um to take a test measure
address
adjust approach and also to think about
the global opportunities beyond just
one-offs and prototypes but really to
uh to think about global opportunities
to scale so one of the things that we'll
look for in the founders that we work
with is
do you have the opportunity to scale to
over 100 cities over the next two to
five years because we don't think that
we have a whole lot of time to
to figure this out um and so
you know if you believe that we face
this massive challenge i think the
question is you know how do we
how do we solve how do we solve for this
and i think
um that we have to start with the
premise that the city is a platform that
for too long
um it has been siloed uh between
infrastructure the built environment and
people
and we think that there are these new
approaches
and new technological drivers
that are helping to blur some of these
lines and create new opportunities for
value creation
one of those driving forces
is the fact that sensors are cheap
they are everywhere and the data that
they generate
can actually be used and acted on
in ways that impact urban planning
in ways that impact transportation
planning
in ways that ultimately again reduce the
the carbon um intensity of our
daily activities and so again you know
thinking about
how do you approach this problem in a
way where you can challenge the status
quo
is something that i think the best
entrepreneurs
are willing to entertain and
um it really is a community of people
from
all around the world i think who are
picking up this mantle
and tackling some of these society scale
issues and
and at urban acts we're trying to uh
build a global community
um of the people who are who are
tackling this challenge of
of climate and um and better cities more
equitable
more enjoyable safer uh
cities because ultimately i think that
is where this
this fight will be won or will be lost
and we talk about cities we really talk
about
seven uh key sectors um
where we think again there are
opportunities for
for real value creation and for venture
scale returns
um and within these cities um uh
within these with these different
sectors we've seen a whole lot of
activity
uh on the built environment primarily
because the program had been based in
new york and i think
you know just globally a whole lot of
activity
around uh prop tech but again
you know i think that there are um
uh massive opportunities across the
board and in many ways
um in between the lines of these
different
uh uh subsets so i wanted to share a
couple of the
um uh ideas um
that we have helped to commercialize and
and to bring to life
um to give you a sense of um
the kinds of solutions that
entrepreneurs are developing
and that customers are asking for so we
back to a company called industrial or
organic which is focused on the issue of
food waste here in new york city about
40
of our municipal waste is actually
organic
and can be composted and so we think
that
again for for cities around the world
you have to start looking at
solid waste in this case industrial
organic actually
was just sold they make a cleaning
product
from organic waste um on
um micro mobility which i think is has
really been
is kind of coming into its own during
the pandemic
um you know how do you get people uh
ultimately to have a safer experience on
their
bike or their e-scooter and part of that
is getting them to wear a helmet
um we backed a company called park and
diamond which developed this really
interesting tessellated
foldable compact helmet for use on
bikes and scooters
another interesting startup is near
space labs
they are uh um
really pioneering an interesting
approach to
uh data um to getting um
real-time insights without having to
launch satellites
so actually using um
weather balloons launching them into the
stratosphere
and using that for insight into activity
in retail disaster management
and so on it's not just hardware it's
also
software we have a really interesting
team called sapien industries it's
looking at commercial
energy efficiency which really is the
the first fuel so savings for commercial
uh building owners they've built an
autonomous energy management system
which is saving commercial landlords a
significant amount of money and
on all of their plug load um
we're also interested in teams who are
making urban spaces and and public space
more fun
uh this is a startup called hubster uh
out of denmark if you see on the wall
uh over there they've uh they've built a
lockable
um box that contains
play equipment and so i'm trying to
activate
uh play through technology and and
really bring people together around
enjoyment of of public space
um i know urban farming and urban ag is
really big in
in singapore we backed a company called
farm shelf
with a really interesting approach to um
urban ag servicing hotels and
restaurants and consumers all around the
world
we're really interested in data on city
streets
this is an interesting company called
numina which is working
in about 20 different cities around the
world
providing insights as to what's actually
happening on
city streets and their tagline is
intelligence without surveillance
but a number of different use cases from
um
you know how often is garbage actually
being picked up
to our people actually following social
distancing guidelines
um we're also really interested in
um first responders and and how you make
roads
safer um so we we backed a company
called
pilot which makes sequential led flares
for traffic accidents and things that
are happening on
on the roadway and this is a really
interesting team again with with
traction and
customers all around the world
early on in the program we backed a
founder out of new zealand who started a
company called
ao air looking at reinventing the face
masks so this was again
almost four years ago now and his value
proposition was that the face mask
hadn't been reinvented
really since it was first introduced and
i think that
you all in singapore have a whole lot
more experience and i think comfort
with masks than most americans do but
this uh this is a really interesting
approach to
to clean air and uh and and to
ultimately safeguarding public health um
we're interested in the in the future of
the cold chain
um how do you maintain um
a safe environment not only for food but
now increasingly for
uh for vaccines to make sure that
temperature is maintained so
this is a really interesting startup
called therma using iot to ensure the
integrity of the
of the cold chain um ava
is a drone company uh really focused on
drone infrastructure
uh also uh being used for disaster
response and and
being deployed internationally um
metalmark is a really neat materials
company that was
inspired by butterfly wings it's a
biomimetic
catalysis company that is focused on
improving
indoor air quality hades is focused on
sewage a very unsexy topic area
but one again that that cities um have
neglected to their own
detriment and so they are using ai
to do uh inspection of sewage pipes so
cities can target uh the infrastructure
that ultimately needs to be fixed and
and fix it before there's a break
we're really interested in electric
mobility here at urban x
so we backed a company called charge lab
which has built an open software
platform for electric vehicle chargers
we think
the proliferation of charging
infrastructure is really important for
more livable cities
evolve energy takes a really interesting
approach
uh on um pricing and getting
more renewables into residential
homes and um and they have a model that
ultimately helps to make
energy cheaper and get more renewables
into the grid this company was actually
just recently acquired
um trow is a startup focused on
climate control and air conditioning
again another massive
issue in singapore they have built a
system
uh that's um uh that uses half
of of the electricity of of traditional
uh ptac window air conditioning units
and also
uh can do heating as well so it's a
novel heat exchange
technology um circuit is an electric
transportation company focused on
first and last mile zero emission had
subsidized
people really really love this service i
like to say that circuit is a a cash
flow positive
um ride hail company with operations
again in more than 20 cities here in the
us
and um you know with that i
i just want to make the call for um
founders and
and entrepreneurs and designers and
engineers who are tackling
some of these big challenges if you have
a solution and are looking for help
with customer development and traction
go to market
development and fundraising here in the
u.s
we would absolutely love to talk to you
i hope you all stay
safe i hope that you continue to be
excellent to each other
and enjoy the rest of tech innovation
thank you
good afternoon i'm delighted to be here
today to talk to you about how we can
prepare our cities
for pandemics but imagine this
imagine if we built our cities in a way
that had
built-in resilience for business and
life continuity
and that's what the idea of the
community block is all about
there's a wonderful quote by arundhati
roy nothing could be worse than a return
to normality
historically pandemics have forced
humans to break with the past
and imagine their world in you this one
is no different it's a portal or gateway
between one world and next and that is
my hope our hope
that after the year we've had what it
does for design
of our buildings of our neighborhoods of
our cities
will be so much better we knew
our cities had a problem when we started
seeing
worldwide of really foundational change
this is time square before and after the
pandemic
everything stopped and the fragility of
our cities
became so evident
we realized perhaps after a long time
that the health of humans the health of
systems
and our economic health was completely
interlinked
and so we started asking ourselves some
really fundamental questions
how can we keep cities sustainable
innovative and accessible
while creating resiliency in the face of
future pandemics
is it possible for us to survive the
next disease
outbreak without going through complete
lockdowns
can we conceive of a city block a
specific area
residents business owners even public
buildings that share a common purpose
which is built on a foundation of health
and wellness and is resilient
to pandemics in other words can we
maintain
business and life continuity through a
pandemic
by design and we really laser focused
on communities because we realized that
worldwide especially in the us
the approaches were either individual
focused
or really policy focused but the missing
rank
was a community and communities have the
power to enforce guidelines and support
individuals
not through laws but through social
bonds and physical connections
and that's what this idea of a prototype
community block is where
you really start with the premise that
the community
is the health system and you shift
dependency from self sufficiency
to really interdependency from rigidity
to flexibility
and most importantly from disparity to
equity
so what you'll see me share with you is
a range of strategies that start talking
about how we can achieve it
at its crux the concept of a community
block
is a community-based ecosystem that
supports
business and life continuity
it could be as a city block it could be
as a campus
it could be as a building the evidence
supporting it
is from urban studies on one end and
infection prevention on the other
and again the same idea that life
continuity
is business continuity and a resilient
solution works for human
environmental and physical health
there are six principles in the
community block
one it should be self-sustaining to
improve both
environmental health and social health
two
you have to have an integrated digital
infrastructure where
every footprint has a corresponding
cloud print so if you have to move
from physical space to digital space and
back again you can do that seamlessly
the idea of circuit and circuit breakers
which really is something singapore gave
to the rest of the world
allows the community to contain certain
sections
while continuing business and life in
others it's a powerful concept
the idea of flexible and mobile
infrastructure
we can no longer afford to have
infrastructure that is only
fixed but if you have flexibility and
mobility
you can have when needed rapid
adaptation
and decompression mixed-use
intergenerational and inclusive
approaches
can make so much of a difference so that
if one business takes a hit
the other one can really fill in
the intergenerational concept as well we
know how our
seniors and our aging adults were
overwhelmingly impacted
but if the strongest in the community
had been able to take care of them
then we wouldn't have to put all the
pressure on health care systems
and then finally all of this depends on
health
housing and education as the
cornerstones that support business and
life continuity
and to achieve these six principles
we have proposed 12 design strategies
and i really believe that these
strategies will keep evolving
many of you watching today will build
your own strategies
but they range anywhere from locally
produced food
to mixed-use multicultural community
development to urban park
networks rather than just having central
green spaces
intergenerational zoning like imagine if
senior living
and schools were co-located and adjacent
and could
really compensate for each other the
idea of thresholds we have seen how
important in between spaces have been
finding a way of leveraging that
connector spaces become wonderful buffer
spaces
as well um circuits and circuit breakers
being able to know what areas i can
quickly close off
having that positive building so that
you really are self-sustaining as a
community
the half-mile neighborhood a lot has
been written on that
if you can really reach things you need
without having to get on public
transport
it makes it so much more resilient cloud
print support we are no longer
able to separate our physical and
digital needs it has to be an integrated
approach
mobile infrastructure the idea of having
mobile carts
mobile clinics mobile libraries mobile
schools
that can be supporting the community
normally
but can quickly reconfigure during a
pandemic
ventilation and daylight has become so
important in this last year
and then thinking about mobility in
multiple scales
so if one scale of mobility becomes at
risk you have other scales that you can
rely on
right and the idea would be that if you
followed these strategies you would have
a
beautiful healthy community walkable
psychosocially supportive these mobile
pods could be distributed all over
as mobile clinics mobile art galleries
mobile libraries mobile schools
the idea of urban farms that produce
local food
really having visual and physical access
to nature
constantly so that you can improve
mental and physical health
these are all not new principles but
when you bring them together
you create a foundation of health and
wellness
and if you think about it in terms of
pandemic resilience
you think about just six levels that you
can pull
and imagine this that when you are
getting into a pandemic
hopefully we would not again but if we
do
or if we are needing it for the second
or the third wave
you have six levers that you can quickly
pull
that are activated by the community
these are checkpoints and access
circulation and flow making sure that
access to essential services is
maintained
during a normal mode people go to
essential services during pandemic board
essential services go to people and
that's where the mobility comes in
program shift being able to say okay
when hospitals need more space hotels
are going to be able to give it when
senior living
is compromised schools can be that
leftover space
understanding all of your community
assets
and understanding and planning for
resource sharing
so that no one is overburdened
de-densification and pedestrianization
and contact tracing so that you can
contain quickly
but imagine if contact racing is also
mobilized by the community
so you are not really fearing for
privacy as much because it's based on a
trust system
these are all really simple levers but
you pull them
and this wonderful block that you had
just
moves into pandemic mode and still
maintains life continuity so mixed-use
zoning for example
allows a hotel to flex from a hotel to a
quarantine facility
homes have thresholds so they can seek
the community they can visually connect
even though they're physically distant
there's limited car transportation but
you have pedestrianized streets to
distribute essential goals
you can start immediately protecting
your
compromised immuno-compromised
populations
and immediately create almost a wall of
defense around them
without compromising their social health
one of the toughest decisions we've had
to make in these times
is that to keep someone physically safe
we have had to compromise their
psychological safety
but if you build on a foundation of
health and wellness and you think about
what levers you can pull
you can maintain their social health as
well
so all of these strategies and
everything that i'm sharing with you is
open source
you can avail off the full document
um anytime that you need but this idea
of thinking of a very flexible system
that things to different scenarios but
because
it's built on health and wellness it can
flex
so easily for example what was an
urban farm and a grocery store can just
become a food delivery hub
and all these little mobile units that
were distributed across your community
now become centralized areas for testing
for tracing for triage maybe even mobile
schools when
children can't go to the school the
schools come to the neighborhoods
that's the level of flexibility and
mobility that we need
the idea that i can go from normal mode
to pandemic mode
because i've built on health and
wellness
and the other key component to making
this work
is you have to work as a system across
the design continuum
all the way from apps so apps that are
for healthy eating
healthy lifestyles could be the same
apple community which uses for contact
racing
natural light and indoor outdoor schemes
those work in normal times as well
but during a pandemic they become our
lifeline
ventilation and daylighting that you're
providing with threshold zones
also serve as buffer zones so what
you're seeing in the top row
is what i would do for health and
wellness and what you're seeing in the
bottom row
is the ability to really give pandemic
resilience
with the same attributes and this idea
is not completely no right in your
backyard
the torpio neighborhood is exactly like
that it's a high-density town
that has supported business and life
continuity right
because you had a mixed use plan and
design overall because you had
pedestrianized streets and rooftops and
food stalls and rec
centers and open parks and open spaces
that neighborhood could still continue
this range of affordances that were
allowed
in that block in the city allowed
residents not to travel out of the
community when it was dangerous
and not to rely on public transport as
much
the other piece that is fascinating
about this neighborhood is about
the really mixed ethnicity that it
supported
the whole multicultural concept and
that's really really important as well
because it gives you a covert advantage
when your needs
are met within the community ventilation
solar panels void decks all of these
have helped you
in having pandemic resilience vertical
farming continuous ground floor parks
walkable neighborhoods
third places ability to support
different mobility devices
these are all ideas that thrive even a
new neighborhood we're designing
in san diego right now has the same
concepts very mixed use
ability to translate access to nature in
daylight
access to air ability to spatially be
distant
even when you're socially connected so
important right now
and all of these good design principles
with
digital infrastructure integrated make a
difference because they
allow us to shift between the physical
and digital as needed
in the end what we hope
this entire year has taught us is
three or four fundamental shifts one
we have realized that i'm not just
responsible for my health
i am responsible for your health and you
are responsible for mine
so we have to survive really
as a community we have to thrive as a
community
the shift from aesthetics to synthetics
we know how we experience
things matters the shift from physical
to digital and from physical to
physical there you realize that our
digital and physical
realities are integrated and most
importantly perhaps even as we go
through
all of these shifts and understand that
our
worlds are so intrinsically
interwoven that we are finally realizing
in 2020 that a purely human-centered
world
will not get us where we need to be we
have to shift from being
human-centered to living-centered
and think like an ecosystem
really celebrating differences
celebrating interdependencies and
understanding
that being a community gives us health
makes us resilient thank you
so much for your time